Profesora Tamar Gendler: El
tema de la clase de hoy,
como pueden ver en el
título, es la libertad.
La mejor manera de entender el
proyecto que nos ocupa hoy
es contrastar las páginas que abren
Teoría de la justicia de Rawls
y las primeras de Anarquía,
Estado y Utopía de Nozick.
Recordarán que, cuando leíamos a Rawls
(por alguna razón el control
remoto no funciona:
es una lástima, pero sigamos),
Rawls comienza su libro
hablando de la justicia
como la primera virtud de las
instituciones sociales.
La justicia tiene el mismo papel
para la legitimidad de las instituciones
que la verdad tiene para un
sistema de pensamiento.
Cada persona, dice Rawls,
"posee una inviolabilidad
basada en la justicia
que ni siquiera el bienestar general
de la sociedad puede superar".
Por esta razón, dice Rawls en las
primeras páginas del libro:
"la justicia refuta el que la
pérdida de libertad de algunos
esté justificada por el
bien mayor de otros".
Así, a Rawls le importa que la
inviolabilidad de la persona
se base en una noción de justicia.
A Nozick también le importa un
tipo de inviolabilidad.
Sin embargo, en vez de hallar el
núcleo de dicha inviolabilidad
en alguna noción de justicia,
la encuentra basada en una
noción de derechos.
Dice en las primeras
líneas del prefacio,
la primera oración que
leyeron para hoy.
"Los individuos tienen derechos
y hay cosas que ninguna persona
o grupo puede hacerles
sin que se violen esos derechos".
Continúa: "el Estado mínimo,
limitado estrictamente a las funciones
de protección contra la fuerza,
el hurto, el fraude, el
cumplimiento de contratos, etc.
es la más amplia labor estatal
que puede justificarse".
Cualquier estado más allá
del estado mínimo
viola los derechos de las personas.
Vemos, pues, que pasa
algo extraordinario
en este par de obras.
A ambos les importa la
cuestión fundamental
que ya hallábamos en el
contexto de Hobbes:
¿cuál es la legitimidad para
que exista el Estado?
Los dos pretenden estructurar al Estado
de tal manera que éste no viole aquello
que perciben como inviolable.
Mas difieren profundamente
en qué clase de Estado acabar
llamando legítimo.
Quizás porque al centro de
la visión de Rawls
yace una noción de justicia,
mientras que en la de Nozick hay
una noción de derechos.
Lo que quiero hacer hoy es contrastar
algunos de los temas que
hallamos la clase pasada
en el contexto de Teoría de
la Justicia de Rawls,
revisando un famoso
capítulo en particular
de Anarquía, Estado y Utopía de
su colega, Robert Nozick.
Ya incluso en las breves selecciones
de estas obras que leyeron,
las diferencias entre ambos autores
han de resultarles evidentes.
Las escribieron con tres
años de diferencia.
Teoría de la Justicia de Rawls
se publicó en 1971.
Anarquía, Estado y Utopía de Nozick,
tres años después, en 1974.
Por entonces, Rawls y Nozick
trabajaban en oficinas a un
pasillo de distancia.
Si bien, como llegarán a
notar, la obra de Rawls
es parte de un proyecto
filosófico más grande...
...uno
extraordinariamente
introspectivo.
Rawls estaba en su mediana edad
cuando lo escribió.
Y ha continuado reflexionando sobre
estas cuestiones por décadas.
El libro de Nozick es una respuesta
increíblemente aguda a Rawls,
al mismo tiempo que la formulación
positiva de una postura.
Mas no se trata de un libro con la
gravedad de Teoría de la Justicia.
Nozick era muy joven
cuando lo escribió:
estaba en su treintena temprana.
También es importante saber que,
si bien ambas obras suelen
estudiarse a la par
en cursos de filosofía (si
tomaron o están tomando
Fundamentación moral de la
política o alguna introducción
a teoría política, se toparán
con los dos libros juntos),
Teoría de la Justicia
es tres veces más influyente
que Anarquía, Estado y Utopía.
Basta con ver la frecuencia
con que se cita.
Sólo en Google Scholar, Teoría de
la Justicia aparece citado
alrededor de 30,000 veces,
frente a las 10,000
de Anarquía, Estado y Utopía.
Números asombrosamente
altos en filosofía.
Aquellos de ustedes que se hayan
topado con obras de otras ramas
de la filosofía, como El nombrar y
la necesidad de Saul Kripke,
que data de esta misma época,
aparece apenas la mitad de veces
que el libro de Nozick:
alrededor de 5,000.
Lo que quiero que se lleven
a casa es la idea
de que éstas son obras de
enorme influencia,
más allá incluso de la filosofía
académica, pero de distinto tono.
Anarquía, Estado y Utopía
intenta defender
un Estado mínimo contra dos tipos
diferentes de objeciones.
En la primera parte del libro,
Nozick defiende al Estado contra
la postura anarquista.
Argumenta que un Estado
mínimo se justifica
porque no viola los derechos
básicos de las personas
al hacer cumplir la ley, con
su labor policial
o con la clase de requisitos
fundamentales necesarios
para remontar el estado de
naturaleza hobbesiano.
En la segunda parte, como
ya ustedes leyeron,
defiende el Estado mínimo contra
una visión maximalista.
Allí mismo, Nozick defiende los
derechos de las personas
a la libertad en dos rubros precisos.
Uno es el derecho de las
personas de acordar
casi cualquier tipo de
contrato que quisieren.
Defiende, por ejemplo, el
derecho de las personas,
bajo ciertas circunstancias, de acordar
un contrato que los esclavice.
O, en otro contexto,
propugna el derecho de hacer un
contrato de chantaje.
Aunque ésa no es la parte del libro
de la que tomamos nuestros extractos.
De donde los tomamos
es la parte a la que dedicaremos
el resto de la clase.
Es decir, el análisis de Nozick sobre
nuestra relación con la propiedad.
Lo que intenta hacer Nozick en el
famoso séptimo capítulo
de Anarquía, Estado y utopía es
articular una noción de justicia
con respecto a la propiedad
que provea una explicación
ejemplar acerca de la relación
de tres diferentes tipos de dudas que
surgen cuando se cuestiona
si es legítimo que una persona
posea alguna propiedad.
La primera es la cuestión de la
justicia en la adquisición.
¿Bajo qué circunstancias
(cuando adquirimos algo
en un primer momento,
digamos, un jitomate)
mi adquisición es tal que mi
propiedad sobre el objeto
respeta las condiciones de justicia?
Hablaremos de la visión de Nozick sobre
la justicia en la adquisición
en un momento.
La segunda cuestión que ocupa a Nozick
es la justicia en la transferencia.
Es decir, si yo tengo un objeto
y quiero transferirle su
posesión a otra persona,
¿bajo qué condiciones dicha
transferencia preserva la justicia?
Por último, la cuestión
sobre la rectificación
de la injusticia.
Supongan que yo poseo algo
que se me ha quitado de
manera ilegítima:
¿bajo qué circunstancias puedo
reclamar la posesión de tal objeto?
El argumento de Nozick es
que podemos decir
todo cuanto queramos sobre la
justicia y la propiedad
(todo cuanto sea necesario decir
acerca de la distribución de la
propiedad en una sociedad
que no viole los derechos individuales)
apelando a la siguiente
definición inductiva:
Dice: "Si una persona
adquiere una propiedad
respetando la justicia
durante la adquisición,
la persona, P, tiene derecho
a tal propiedad".
Así, si llego yo a poseer algo
de manera legítima,
en concordancia con lo anterior,
mi posesión de ese objeto
mantiene las reglas de la justicia.
La segunda cláusula es una
cláusula de inducción.
"Si una persona adquiere una propiedad,
respetando la justicia
durante la transferencia,
de alguien que tenía derecho
(ya sea como resultado de
otra transferencia
o de adquisición primera)
sobre ese objeto,
entonces esa persona tiene
derecho sobre el objeto".
Finalmente, Nozick tiene una
cláusula de cierre.
"Nadie tiene derecho
sobre una propiedad,
salvo por repetidas aplicaciones
de las cláusulas 1 y 2".
Quienes hayan estudiado matemáticas
reconocerán este tipo de definiciones.
Si yo quisiera proveer una
definición inductiva
de los números naturales,
podría empezar diciendo que
"uno es miembro del conjunto de
números naturales".
Ésa sería mi cláusula base.
Añado entonces que
"si algo es miembro del conjunto
de números naturales,
por tanto, ese algo y uno son miembros
del conjunto de números naturales".
Coloco entonces una cláusula de
cierre como condición,
de tal manera que "los números
naturales", por ejemplo,
"son únicamente todos aquellos
que satisfagan la primera y
segunda cláusulas".
Así, la visión que nos da Nozick aquí
es un cierto tipo de sistema cerrado.
Veamos, pues, cómo funciona
en un caso particular.
Nozick subraya que, cuando se
utilicen los principios
que ha articulado aquí, lo importante
es el proceso y no el resultado.
Supongan que yo poseo un jitomate.
Según Nozick, toda la
diferencia radica en el proceso
de cómo llegué yo a poseer ese objeto.
Si, por ejemplo, había un jardín
por allí, que no era mío,
donde crecía un bonito jitomate, y
yo lo cogí sin permiso,
mi posesión sobre el
jitomate es ilegítima.
Mmm.
Tampoco importa si, mediante un
proceso alternativo (hipotético),
yo haya podido llegar
a adquirir legítimamente el jitomate.
Si un ladrón te quita tu
propiedad, dice Nozick,
su posesión sobre el
objeto no es legítimo
aun si voluntariamente se lo diste,
Más todavía,
si yo adquiero algo de manera
ilegítima y te lo transfiero
(incluso si es de manera legítima),
mantiene su estado de ilegitimidad.
La visión que Nozick
presenta en su análisis
de la propiedad tiene, pues, las
siguientes características:
La justicia en torno a la propiedad
(y esto será importante para
su crítica a Rawls)
es histórica.
Es decir, depende de lo que
de hecho sucedió.
Particularmente, si algo se posee
como resultado de una
adquisición injusta,
produce una propiedad injusta.
Si algo se posee como resultado de
una adquisición injusta
más una transferencia justa,
de todos modos produce una
propiedad injusta.
Si algo se posee como resultado
de una adquisición justa
pero una transferencia injusta,
produce una propiedad injusta.
Y si algo se posee como resultado
de una adquisición injusta
y una transferencia injusta,
no hace que las dos injusticias
se cancelen entre sí.
Más bien, tenemos, de nuevo,
una propiedad injusta.
Es sólo bajo dos condiciones
que la propiedad es justa para Nozick.
La primera es una honesta y
directa adquisición justa.
Y la segunda es que una
adquisición justa sea seguida
por una o más transferencias justas.
Hasta ahora, esto no ha llevado a
Nozick muy lejos de Rawls.
Mas el próximo paso que da les
hará ver cómo esta noción
de propiedad funciona en la
visión general de Nozick.
Lo que Nozick dice a continuación
es que la propiedad de una
persona es justa
si tiene derecho sobre ella según
los principios de justicia
en la adquisición y la transferencia
o en situaciones imperfectas
según el principio de rectificación.
Esto es: que una condición
necesaria para la propiedad
es que haya sido adquirida mediante uno
de los dos pasos siguientes.
Aunque también se trata de una
condición suficiente.
Si las propiedades de cada
persona son justas,
no hay más que cuestionar en cuanto a
la acumulación de propiedades.
Si las propiedades de cada
persona son justas,
la distribución de
propiedades es justa.
Veremos, cuando lleguemos a la
justicia de transferencia,
cómo es que esta noción, al hacer de
las propiedades históricas
las más relevantes a la hora de
determinar la justicia
y al tomar la caracterización
inductiva de la posesión
como necesaria y suficiente para que
haya justicia en la propiedad;
o bien, cómo es que estas dos
cosas dan a Nozick una base
desde la cual criticar lo
que, según ustedes
(o la mayoría de ustedes),
manda la justicia desde detrás
del velo de la ignorancia
de la clase pasada.
Es decir, Nozick parte de este
simple argumento, que,
desde su perspectiva, torna ilegítimo
cualquier tipo de redistribución
centralizada de recursos.
Recordarán ustedes que,
en aras de evaluar la
definición inductiva de Nozick,
necesitamos saber qué
piensa él que conlleva
la justicia en la adquisición.
Y en qué consiste la justicia
durante la transferencia.
De tal forma que la discusión acerca de
la justicia en la adquisición
es una parte harto complicada del texto
que les pedí leer para la clase de hoy.
Lo que hace Nozick es apelar a la obra
del filósofo del siglo XVII
John Locke, cuyo Segundo Tratado
sobre el Gobierno Civil
comienza analizando la
propiedad como sigue...
Escribe Locke: "Aunque la tierra y
todas las criaturas inferiores
sean comunes a todos los hombres,
todo hombre guarda la
propiedad de sí mismo.
"Con lo que nadie tiene
ningún derecho sobre otro,
más que sobre sí mismo.
"La labor de su cuerpo y el trabajo de
sus manos, podríamos decir,
son propiamente suyos y de nadie más".
Por lo que, en la visión de Locke,
en el estado de naturaleza
existe un mundo externo
sin propietarios.
Dejemos de lado algunas
objeciones a esta visión
(como que la tierra o las
criaturas inferiores
le pertenezcan rectamente a
los seres humanos)
y concentrémonos en qué
consiste la cláusula de Locke
sobre la justicia en la adquisición.
Locke dice que el mundo
externo con sus objetos
no le pertenece a nadie.
Sin embargo, lo que cada persona tiene
no es sino el derecho sobre su propio
cuerpo y, particularmente,
la posesión o derecho de
propiedad sobre su trabajo.
Dice Locke: "Cualesquiera cosas que
[el hombre] sacare del estado
que la naturaleza ha provisto
y dejado para que,
combinado con su labor y unido
a algo que es suyo,
serán, en adelante, su propiedad".
Y concluye: "Al ser removido por
él del estado común
que la naturaleza dispuso por
medio de su trabajo,
aquello queda excluido del derecho
común de otros hombres."
Puesto que este trabajo es, sin lugar a
dudas, propiedad del trabajador,
ningún hombre tiene derecho a aquello
que ya ha sido transformado
por labor de otro.
Siempre y cuando quede, bien y
suficientemente, algo para los otros".
Nozick, pues, toma dos cosas
del análisis de Locke.
La primera idea que toma es que la
justicia en la adquisición
conlleva una cierta mezcla de
aquello que es mío,
mi trabajo, con aquello que no
tiene dueño anterior:
la propiedad potencial en el
estado de naturaleza.
Y aunque Nozick hace todo
tipo de críticas
contra la poca claridad de
esta caracterización...
...dice, por ejemplo: "Si voy a Marte y
arranco un trozo del planeta,
¿acaso he reclamado como
mío ese pedazo? "
¿O he reclamado el planeta entero? "
¿O reclamé todos los planetas
más allá de Marte?".
También se pregunta por la mezcla entre
algo y el trabajo de alguien:
¿por qué se concluye la
propiedad del objeto
y no la pérdida del trabajo?
En última instancia, está dispuesto a
aceptar que algo de la visión
lockeana estará detrás de la
justicia de adquisición.
Lo que le preocupa, al grado de
dedicarle la mayor parte
de la selección que leyeron anoche,
es el problema de lo que llama
la "estipulación lockeana"
o la idea de que,
para que una adquisición sea
legítima, es necesario que reste,
con suficiencia y en buen estado,
algo del bien en cuestión
para los otros.
Y si esa estipulación es
frecuentemente atropellada o no.
Puesto que, si la estipulación es
violada con frecuencia,
la justicia en las adquisiciones
no sería ni remotamente
lo que Nozick quiere que sea.
La estructura básica del
argumento que leyeron
(y repararé en ella con mayor
detalle en un momento)
en el contexto de Nozick
es como sigue:
Locke tiene una visión razonable
de lo que conlleva la
adquisición de propiedad.
Necesitamos quedarnos en las
márgenes del problema,
mas no voy a preocuparme por
ello, dice Nozick.
Por lo que voy a preocuparme es si
esta noción de que haya
"con suficiencia y en buen estado,
algo restante para
disfrute de los otros"
mina o no toda la visión lockeana.
¿Cómo concretar esta idea?
Supongamos que cuatro de nosotros
nos topamos con un campo lleno de
vacas sin dueño alguno.
Y que uno de nosotros
clama cuatro vacas.
Luego, que otro clama seis
vacas y el tercero,
las seis restantes.
¿Se ha violado la
estipulación lockeana?
La primera preocupación de Nozick,
que él llama
preocupación
"desabrochada",
es que, tal vez, no es sólo
que el sujeto azul
que clamó las últimas seis vacas
haya violado la
estipulación lockeana...
...sino también que el sujeto
amarillo, al limitar al azul,
lo ha violado; y que el rojo,
al limitar al amarillo que
limitó al azul,
también violó la
estipulación de alguna
manera.
Nozick niega esto.
El hecho de que los actos
del sujeto rojo
limitaron los del amarillo,
si consideramos los actos del azul,
no son suficientes para
achacarles a rojo o amarillo
la violación de la
estipulación lockeana.
Ése es el primer paso.
Aún podemos preguntarnos
si el sujeto azul
violó la estipulación lockeana.
Después de todo, ¿cómo
podría haber dejado
suficientes vacas en buen estado para
el cuarto sujeto (el rosa),
si éste no puede ya
clamar ninguna vaca?
La respuesta de Nozick es que al
tomar posesión de objetos
y mezclar el propio trabajo con
estos, lo que típicamente sucede
es que el sujeto aumenta el valor
de esos objetos para todos.
Por lo que rojo, de sus cuatro vacas,
puede producir un galón de leche.
Amarillo, quizá dos y azul, tres.
Como resultado, el sujeto rosa
(a pesar de no tener acceso a las
vacas) está mejor sin ellas.
Para Nozick, la estipulación de
Locke no fue violada.
Es decir: Nozick pregunta
si la situación
de quienes no están en
condiciones de apropiarse de nada
(al no haber más objetos
apropiables o sin dueño)
empeora con un sistema que
permita la apropiación
y la propiedad privada.
Contesta tajantemente que no.
Justo por las mismas razones
que conocemos del caso Hobbes
(la idea de que existe un tipo de
contrato social que, al efectuarse,
permite beneficiarse a todos).
Asimismo, Nozick cree con firmeza en
que la propiedad individual
trae consigo un peculiar
tipo de eficiencia.
Su preocupación inicial era si
la estipulación lockeana
desbarataría su teoría
y la cláusula base de su
argumento inductivo.
Él concluye que la
apropiación de propiedad
privada
satisface la intención de
la estipulación:
"que reste con suficiencia
y en buen estado".
Si bien tiene el cuidado de señalar
que no se basa en un
razonamiento utilitario.
No se basa en una justificación
utilitaria de la propiedad.
A Nozick, igual que Rawls, le
importa articular una teoría
basada en los derechos.
Por lo que, como Rawls,
no acepta cambiar derechos por utilidad.
Así, el argumento sobre la
adquisición de propiedad
se desarrolla como sigue:
Nozick dice: yo tengo el
derecho de hacer todo
cuanto no dañe a otros
y el derecho de hacer sólo
aquello que no dañe a otros.
Mis derechos comienzan y terminan en
las restricciones y permisos
que consideran lo que daña a otros.
Violar la estipulación
lockeana, aun si logro hacerlo,
dejaría a otros peor que si
no lo hubiera hecho,
y les estaría haciendo daño.
Como consecuencia, dice Nozick,
no tengo el derecho de violar la
estipulación lockeana.
Si, de hecho, mi
adquisición original no
deja,
con suficiencia y en buen estado,
algo para otros, entonces,
mi adquisición no es una
instancia justa de propiedad.
Sin embargo, añade Nozick,
salvo en raros casos
(que llama condiciones de catástrofe o
limitaciones de isla desierta),
la adquisición de propiedad no
viola la estipulación lockeana
ni daña a otros.
Y el argumento para esta
cláusula secundaria,
o este argumento secundario,
están basados en la utilidad.
Es sobre la base de la utilidad
que obtengo esta premisa:
que sólo en raros casos la
adquisición de propiedad
no viola la estipulación lockeana.
Mas el argumento fundamental es
que tengo el derecho
de hacer todo y sólo cuanto
no dañe a otros.
Salvo en raros casos, la
adquisición de propiedad
no viola la estipulación
lockeana y daña a otros.
Ésa, más cuatro, basta
para concluir que,
salvo en casos raros,
tengo derecho a adquirir propiedades.
He allí, pues, la
explicación de lo que sé
fue una parte un tanto
difícil del texto asignado.
Vayamos, pues, a un segmento
del texto más sencillo.
Tal como vimos, Nozick defiende
su cláusula de base
apelando a la noción de Locke de
adquisición original de propiedad
y refuta una potencial objeción
(la estipulación lockeana)
clarificándola.
De varias maneras, la más
célebre parte del texto
es donde Nozick defiende su
cláusula de inducción.
Al defender la cláusula de inducción
(que, recordarán, dice que
si P adquiere H,
de acuerdo con la justicia
de transferencia
y de alguien con derecho a la cosa,
entonces P tiene derecho sobre H),
Nozick quiere saber en qué consiste
la justicia de transferencia.
Comienza distinguiendo algo que debería
resultarles familiar a ustedes
luego de sus lecturas de Mill y Kant
al principio del semestre.
Distingue entre principios históricos
(que nos dicen si una
distribución es justa
dependiendo de cómo se realizó).
Es decir, lo que interesa
cuando hablamos de
justicia es la cuestión del proceso.
Él contrasta estos principios
con los principios que llama
de fin y resultado,
donde si una distribución es justa o no
depende de cómo se
distribuyen las cosas.
Recordarán que, cuando leíamos a Kant
y tratábamos de determinar si
una acción era moral
o moralmente loable,
al autor le interesaba el
proceso de la acción.
Mill, en cambio, se
interesaba en el resultado.
Nozick, en la primera parte del
séptimo capítulo que hemos leído,
continúa defendiendo los
principios históricos y sostiene
que una consecuencia de ello
es que nunca podremos juzgar la
justicia de una sociedad
considerando cómo están
distribuidos sus bienes.
Así, señala que ha sido típico
para la articulación de teorías
de la justicia sostener
que una sociedad es buena si sus
bienes han sido distribuidos
de acuerdo con alguna clase de criterio
independiente y específico.
Por ejemplo, la distribución de bienes
según el mérito moral de
aquellos quienes los reciben,
o de acuerdo con su inteligencia,
o basándose en el esfuerzo
de los individuos,
o por las necesidades que haya de los
objetos que se distribuyen.
Nozick señala que la gente quiere
que su sociedad parezca justa.
Y también que sea justa.
Pero, al tratar que su
sociedad parezca justa,
Nozick cree que se comete un
error si se toma un criterio
que determine la
legitimidad del resultado.
¿Debe acaso, se pregunta Nozick,
la apariencia de justicia
basarse en el criterio del resultado,
que puede ser específico,
independiente y de antemano,
o sostenerse sobre los principios
de generación subyacentes?
Pensar en ello nos ayuda a hacer
una distinción tripartita
que hace el propio Rawls en
Teoría de la Justicia.
Rawls distingue tres clases
de justicia procesal.
La primera es una noción que llama
justicia procesal perfecta.
Consiste en que se tiene un
criterio independiente
para determinar el correcto
resultado de nuestros actos
y para asegurar que
obtengamos ese resultado.
Así, por ejemplo, si trato
de partir un pastel
del que todos queremos un trozo,
existe un criterio independiente para
saber el resultado correcto.
O sea, que cada uno de nosotros
reciba un pedazo del mismo tamaño.
Con lo que hay un procedimiento certero
para llegar a ese resultado.
Lo que hago es dejar que
una persona lo parta
y que esa persona escoja su
pedazo al último.
Siempre y cuando pueda
hacer cortes precisos,
este procedimiento
arrojará invariablemente
lo que especificamos de
manera independiente
que debería ser el resultado.
Queremos rebanadas iguales, tenemos
un criterio independiente
para el resultado correcto y existe
un procedimiento certero.
Quien lo parte escoge al final.
Por contraste, en la mayoría
de las situaciones,
nos hallamos, más bien,
en la condición
que Rawls llama justicia
procesal imperfecta.
Aquí tenemos un criterio independiente
para determinar el resultado correcto,
mas un procedimiento para
obtenerlo que es imperfecto.
Por ejemplo, en el sistema
legal tenemos como meta
condenar a todos y sólo aquellos que
sean culpables de un crimen.
O sea, tenemos un sentido
claro y distinto
de cuál debe ser el resultado.
Y, sin embargo, a pesar de que
tenemos un procedimiento
que supuestamente funciona
mejor que el azar,
no hay duda de que a veces los
culpables quedan impunes.
Asimismo,
de vez en vez se condena a un inocente.
A la tercera clase de justicia procesal
Rawls la llama justicia procesal pura.
En este caso, no tenemos un
modo independiente
para especificar el resultado.
Lo que hacemos, entonces, es
adoptar un procedimiento
mediante el cual realizaremos alguna
distribución en tiempo real.
Y como resultado de haber
seguido dicho procedimiento,
la distribución resultante,
cualquiera que fuere, será justa.
Apostar tiene esta misma estructura.
Tenemos una sola regla.
Todos pagamos nuestra cuota
y nos arriesgamos.
Cualquier resultado será legítimo.
Nozick proclama que la distribución
de propiedad en una sociedad
ha de ser entendida como sujeto
y no como una especie de justicia
procesal perfecta o imperfecta.
Es decir, que no hay un
criterio independiente
para determinar cómo han de
distribuirse los bienes entre la gente.
Es un asunto más simple:
vivir históricamente un proceso
en el que las cosas son requeridas y
transferidas de manera justa,
y ver cómo es que se distribuyen solas.
En cambio, Marx introdujo esta idea:
"De cada cual de acuerdo
con su habilidad;
para cada cual según sus necesidades".
Ésa es la idea de que existe un
criterio independiente
sobre cómo deberían ser
distribuidos los bienes.
Nozick provee, en cambio, esta
articulación un tanto compleja:
"de cada cual según lo que ha
elegido hacer y, aproximadamente,
a cada cual según sea escogido".
Es decir: no importa cómo se
distribuyan las cosas,
mientras el proceso sea justo, el
resultado será justo.
De lo cual deriva Nozick su
famoso argumento
de que la libertad altera los patrones.
Nozick nos pide que imaginemos un mundo
en el que a todos nuestros amigos
tras el velo de la ignorancia
se les dé la porción igual
cualquiera de bienes que les darían
de acuerdo con una justa distribución.
De tal manera que cada uno acabe
con una alcancía de buen tamaño.
Mas todos ellos, dice Nozick,
son fans del básquetbol
y deciden usar un cuarto de su dinero
para depositarlo en la cuenta de
banco de Wilt Chamberlain.
Y así hacen todos sus amigos,
y los amigos de sus amigos,
y los de éstos,
hasta que, como resultado de
legítimas transferencias,
Wilt Chamberlain tiene tanto dinero
que no cabe ya en sualcancía.
Se ha vuelto extraordinariamente rico.
Para Nozick, el ejemplo de Wilt
Chamberlain tiene dos implicaciones.
La primera es descriptiva.
El punto general, dice, ilustrado por
el ejemplo Wilt Chamberlain,
es que ningún principio de fin estatal
o de patrón distributivo de justicia
puede llevarse a cabo continuamente
sin interferir en la vida
de las personas.
Cualquier patrón favorable
se volverá desfavorable por principio
(por las personas
intercambiando bienes y
servicios
con otras personas o dándole cosas a
otros, cosas sobre las que
quienes las transfieren tienen derecho
bajo el patrón distributivo).
Para mantener un patrón,
uno debe interferir
con el proceso de
transferencia de recursos
o bien interferir de tal manera
que uno le quite a alguien
algo que adquirió legítimamente con
sus centavos y lo redistribuya.
Para mantener un patrón, dice
Nozick, debe uno intervenir
y prevenir que la gente transfiera
bienes como desee o bien,
interferir y tomar de los recursos
que otros decidieron transferirles.
Ésa es la implicación descriptiva
del ejemplo Wilt Chamberlain.
Ahora bien, hay una
implicación normativa.
Dice Nozick: miren si D1, la
distribución inicial
donde cada uno de nuestros personajes
tras el velo de la ignorancia
tiene su alcancía.
D1 fue una distribución justa.
Y la gente voluntariamente se
movió de D1 a D2,
el caso donde Wilt Chamberlain
terminó forrado de centavos.
¿No acaso transferir
parte de sus bienes,
que les fueron dados en D1, hace
que D2 sea también justo?
Si la gente tenía derecho a
disponer de los recursos
a que tenían derecho en D1, ¿no
incluye esto el derecho
a dárselo o hacer un trueque
con Wilt Chamberlain?
¿Puede alguien quejarse de
que hay injusticia?
Cada persona, para Nozick,
ya tiene sus legítimos bienes en D1;
y aun después de algunas
transferencias a Wilt Chamberlain,
sus bienes siguen teniendo la
misma proporción.
La tesis descriptiva es que la libertad
altera los patrones.
Mientras que la normativa
dice que, al hacerlo,
no se comete injusticia.
Cerraré ahora con dos razones
que uno podría pensar
contra el argumento de Nozick,
que no funciona tan
impolutamente como él cree.
La primera ya nos la hemos
encontrado antes:
muchas más situaciones de las que
podemos pensar de antemano
tienen la estructura de los
problemas de los comunes.
Y no es siempre el caso
que las transacciones
individuales entre dos personas
no tengan consecuencias sobre terceros.
La segunda es que, a veces, se da el
caso de que las distribuciones
de recursos entre individuos de manera
desigual produce violaciones
de la clase de libertades que
Nozick quiere defender.
Supongamos que empezamos con
dos grupos de gente,
cada uno con aproximadamente la
misma cantidad de dinero.
Ellos mandan a sus hijos a
la misma escuela
y comparten los mismos maestros.
Supongan ahora que uno de esos grupos,
a través de una transferencia
legítima del tipo D1 a D2,
llega a tener más dinero,
con el cual fundan otra
escuela para sus hijos,
para la cual contratan
maestros más calificados.
Así, puede ser el caso que,
mediante simples conductas
que involucran una serie de
transferencias legítimas,
la situación resultante inhiba la
libertad de estos niños
de volverse la clase de ciudadanos
cuyos derechos Nozick defiende.
Son las 11:20 ahora.
Dejemos aquí la clase.
Pasaremos la siguiente clase para
terminar con el análisis
de Nozick y la justicia de propiedad,
así como pensarla en el contexto de
algún trabajo de psicología social.